hey Billy amen you know Sam real oh it's
good to see you buddy well thank you
Sam's not my regular co-host he's in for
today's Disick you know he's a funny
comedian my regular caller said his wife
had a baby so he took her today salute
so wires six years you just I didn't
realize how long Mike and Molly all
right yes six years mr. Ron's like
catching a unicorn in television these
days writers you know most things are
getting killed after two or three years
we were very lucky to get up into that
syndication levels so it was very cool
that kids every comedians dream is to
get a show that goes into syndication
yeah and Brett Butler
I think [ __ ] up and she was I guess
crazy and difficult but didn't she miss
indication by like five episodes or
something oh god I don't know but that
would be hard for every brutal she was
in LA at 28 the three lead no I'm a
Pittsburgh guy so I really thought for
once New England was gonna lose him okay
you just can't stop it you know yeah
they also fell apart they collapse I was
kind of fun to watch them I had the over
show wasn't all bad
yeah let's see how much you win I had I
bet lightly through the year but then if
I have a pile at the end I put it all on
the Super Bowl so you know ended up with
an extra G so it was nice nice not
nothing not hurt nobody so how did
Michael Molly come about did you did you
write this first order they come to you
with this no man I I was ready to pack
it up and cut Hollywood I was ready to
go I had had you know I guess it was
about 40 weeks on the road a year you
know how it gets yeah ending on the road
and you're like what have I done with my
life and I had a little baby at home it
was two and you know that wears on a
marriage and it's certainly tough it was
a father I I lived in Los Angeles and I
was gonna get a gig on radio cuz I love
radio and I callin every morning to my
hometown Pittsburgh rock station WD ve
every Tuesday do it every morning from
LA every Tuesday we really yeah WD
poor guy and I've been doing them for 12
years and he said why don't you come
back here man cuz I didn't want to be
away from my kid as I look this
joke-telling and you know getting on TV
is not more important to my family so I
said here's what I'll do
I'm gonna ride out one more pilot season
in pilot season is like a three-month
period you know they try to all the new
shows come out and you pray you get a
gig then you pray you get picked up so I
only got six auditions in three months
and the last one was my Kamali Wow
literally a Hail Mary that's [ __ ]
amazing Rose can you say that
radio on sorry man but yeah it was it
was it was it was literally the last
audition are you high so you were ready
to come out I was ready to go man yeah
because you know I had you know my you
know I had had some a real bad bout of
drinking and I was trying to straighten
my life out and I'd had about two years
of not drinking and I just hadn't booked
anything I couldn't get anything and I
was just like you know what man maybe
this is just not for me it's depressing
out there when you're not working right
it's really tough man it's really really
tough and and so I was just like this is
not gonna consume my family in my life
so I'm gonna get my [ __ ] together and
I'm gonna I'm gonna go back to my
hometown and I could do a radio show and
being with a bunch of people I like to
have a good living and then you know
watch my kid grow up and then luckily
Mike and Molly happened and it changed
the game and and your Billy is promoting
Sun Records which I'm guessing is about
Elvis Thursday 10 o'clock on CMT and
that's now is this an ongoing series
yeah it's a 8 hour 8 1 hours episodes
and hopefully if it does well we'll be
doing it again next year and it's about
son it's actually about son studios in
my case which was the birth of rock and
roll it was the place where Sam Phillips
had the vision to to try to find a new
sound and he was unafraid at a very
heightened time and civil rights to
combine the church music with gospel
with hillbilly and then these artists
started showing up at Sun Studios like
BB King Ike Turner Jackie Branson Elvis
Johnny Cash Jerry Lee Lewis and I get to
play Colonel Tom Parker
Elvis's douchebag manager was there
before it was he there with all these
other bands like with Johnny Cash
guys were this this is their journey as
like their young men Johnny Cash is
coming off the firm farm Jerry Lee Lewis
is making instructor Elvises in high
school in Memphis it started 1952 and
the colonel was actually a Dutch
immigrant it came from Holland his name
was andreas von Koch and he came over
here and he left Holland under some very
very shady circumstances there was a
murder this there's no real information
on this guy but by the time he got to
America he invented this character
Colonel Parker and he started by just
pulling scams and cons at carnivals and
and stuff like that so he's a real
huckster and then he got his arms into
Eddie Arnold and for many Arnold he went
to Hanks known formation le finally got
Elvis
Wow so his team is at music manager
before Elvis yeah he while he was just
getting into the music business cuz he
saw a quick buck that's all he cared
about was money I I was lucky enough in
Memphis they opened their arms to us
which was really sure so I got to talk
to people that knew the guy and nobody I
talked to for different people for
separate occasions and nobody described
him the same way it was like I was there
my for different people so the CEO of
Graceland told me said you just got to
kind of play him what a twinkle in his
eye because this guy was whatever the
situation took to get the deal done so
when the music business started to get
hot that's where he saw you know what I
need to get into this but he was the
kind of guy that could sell anything to
anybody and you know he was actually you
know he's an awful guy when it came to
how much money he took from Elvis but at
the same time he was the guy that saw
Elvis and went this guy could be the
king of rock and roll and he was the
first guy to market that stuff okay so
he L he really did help Elvis become
Elvis he really did and in a very
unhealthy way he kept he isolated Elvis
so in an uncommon way he made him feel
safe which is a very weird whole dab
over somebody you know I mean because he
isolated him from his parents he
isolated him from Sam Phillips he
isolated him from Trixie his original
girlfriend and he kept Elvis in this
little bubble but by doing that Elvis
because I was the biggest star in the
world by the time it was 22 years old
that was the place where he felt safe
you know and he had a few the colonel
would let a few of his friends around
him but boy he was a he was a he's a
pretty dark guy wouldn't he not let
Elvis travel overseas because he was a
that was the reason he will
because he was an illegal immigrant he
was afraid that if he took all of us
over there he'd get deported but then he
was scared if he let Elvis go on his own
that somebody would scoop a mock laughs
so he kept him here in America so he
couldn't have sent one of his people
with Elvis
yeah the colonel didn't trust anybody
with Elvis he just did not want anybody
near him had to convince Elvis to not go
overseas you know what I don't know man
we're exploring that as we go and like I
said this guy was so devious you know
he's got the biggest rock star in the
world but he was smart enough to stay in
the shadows there's not much on him
there's not much information on him so
there's one recording with him and Ted
Koppel in an interview but he's like I
know he's almost 89 or something so he's
kind of passed there's not a lot of
video on him yeah and there's calls that
you can like hear old phone
conversations but you really don't get
any any message how old was he when he
scooped up Elvis the colonel yeah I
think he was probably about 42 43
somewhere in there somewhere in that
again everything is sketchy like you can
hear three different stores from three
different people but he was about
twenty-five twenty twenty-five years
Elvis's senior so he talked to Priscilla
I did not get to talk to her but we did
get to talk to some of the Memphis mafia
and we talked to some of the guys that
did some of the guys that were in
business we got to speak Jerry Lee Lewis
was down there and we got to speak with
him and it was just it was an amazing
thing to be a part of because we filmed
there for three months and to be in you
know to go to the the the black gospel
churches where Elvis would sneak in so
he could hear that sound that's what he
wanted you know in 52 he would sneak
into the church service sir could hear
that that sound that's what he wanted
and and then to be in his high school
and to be in the actual Sun Records I
mean it was like it was pretty well I've
been there once I went with though and I
was talking with dice we did a gig down
there and we went to we got a private
tour of Nashville and I mean yeah
Graceland Graceland and we went to this
the studios and I got picture it's such
an awful forum just guys it's the war I
don't like such a tool but it was cool
to be in that room can't help but feel
that when you walk in there and that's
the actual mic they recorded on they let
people grab it i which i think is kind
of cool and you know the first night
we're in Memphis they invited us over
there and
you know here we are you know 50 60
years later and there's a young band and
they're trying to trying to cut a record
yeah and they're still playing in that
studio yeah if they still record every
week did you get to go to Graceland at
all how much access did you have I did I
got we did we got the private tour of
Graceland actually and I think we got to
go to two rooms that aren't normally on
the tour but we didn't get to go
upstairs which is where I wanted to go
nobody gets to go upstairs I wonder why
they don't let anybody upstairs I think
they just keep that part private I don't
know I think it's the family's request
what's out there I don't know that well
there's the bathroom obviously already
passed away but then there's a couple
bedrooms and stuff but you don't get to
see that stuff but was he when he died I
heard a funny story about the jungle for
tea I didn't know the origin of the
jungle room but the jungle room Elvis
did basically to mess with Vern his
father because they were out shopping
and he saw this furniture that he
started insulting and hatin and Elvis
bought all of it and then he had a bay
window removed so that they could bring
all of it in and put a piano in there
and how to repair the window so the
jungle room can't be removed he's 42 Wow
yeah I've been I've been down there and
the upstairs my men one of my managers
got to go Wow because for a while them
the managers I was with they they were
part of the group that controlled
Elvis's estate yeah and so he got to go
up and he told me I get to go upstairs
that's why that's like that's that's
like a visitation with the Pope you
can't get up yeah they have it roped off
and there's an alarm or something I
would if there's really an alarm or if
they just say there's a lodge say that
for people like us yeah did you now how
old was Lisa like the the kid who was
the wife Priscilla Marie is the daughter
I don't know how old she is now but a
Priscilla would have known as well a
saved Graceland because and she was the
one that got Colonel Parker out of
Graceland
it took them you know a team of lawyers
to get him unburied from Grace Lee was
living there yet no but he was involved
with all the money 5050 at that point
you imagine Wow now Elvis went with that
yeah why he had that weird loyalty to
him and I guess they were making so much
or he'd I'm not sure Elvis was really
aware of it because he died what about
him
bucks in the bank can you imagine that
is that it yeah and then now they've
turned but that was probably a decent
amount then right yeah but I'm he should
have made way more than that exactly but
the colonel Parker you know that again
that the CEO of Grayson told me his luck
he is you can justify 30% of Elvis's
money for the colonel yes cuz look you
paying that you pay a agent you pay a
manager you pay a publicist you pay a
lawyer okay if you have a pretty
successful sure you know that's ten ten
five five that's you you're right there
at thirty percent but he just went too
far with it and he just went and then
there was all the side deals that he
would get to he was greedy awful and it
had a horrible gambling addiction as
well oh what's I'm looking forward to
playing I hope we'll get into that do
you think oh I did some research for
that hahaha [ __ ] a lot of girls be
jealous his manager he wasn't gave her
any was he no I don't think he was too
much of a womanizer he was he had
because he had such trust issues they
kind of touch on that in the first
episode there was a there was a
prostitute that he that was like the
only person he would talk the truth to
because he just thought so around her so
she was the only one he kind of trusted
so they touched on that in the first
series but the colonel was very very
guarded me she didn't know yes
we don't know we don't know what her
actual name was I don't know if it was
the an authentic name but I we do know
this story happened but it was just a
woman that he felt safe to tell
everything it was like who he could be
himself around with he marries oh but
we've never gotten hold of her to talk
to her I don't even know if she's alive
he eventually got married later on he
got married yeah did you ever know I
asked you to about about Melissa
McCarthy's doing so great with fillers
awesome so you guys still closer you
don't yeah I know yeah we were trying to
figure out she's in New York right now
so we're trying to figure out sometime
down a coffee she's uh she's doing
movies and stuff and that was the
greatest cast man I really stepped into
it wouldn't happened because we had no
whack jobs there was no crazy for six
years it was the greatest job on earth
there was nobody and I think it's
because everybody was over 40 right so
there was none of that like that I need
to throw a fit there was none of that it
was you know have you had a gig we were
just so grateful man so grateful and
then
credit when her star took off and I mean
it took off like we haven't seen since
like Eddie Murphy yeah she came into
work the same kind person every day the
same person has started with daddy you
know we only have a couple of minutes
left
Billy is promoting thanks Rob by the way
you're a great comedian man I'm a great
comedian that's thanks plenty of Sam but
I'm saying thank you anyway it's Sam Jim
is a comedian I know you have trouble
with compliment thank you for a
phenomenal comedian thank you
I don't know how to think on this you're
right I have no idea say something
hateful tell me to [ __ ] off no promoting
Sun Records Thursday at 10 o'clock on
CMT and it's Billy Gardell two L's at
the end on Twitter knows do you want
Melissa to put you in early are you is
there anything we like she's doing movie
she could put me in a movie you know
what man I never ever ever want to cross
that line with her I love our friendship
my path is my path her path is her path
and I think that respect keeps us very
close and the fact is you had six years
together and you know syndication money
is not small no it's good it's not what
it's not Seinfeld syndication but it's
it's after syndication but you're still
King you know if I call one of my
buddies in Pittsburgh that's drywalling
today I don't think he would want to
hear that I'm not getting as much in sag
as I would have oh yeah yeah you should
complain about that we [ __ ] into a
spackle bucket we gotta close the
computer cuts up anytime buddy I'm happy
for your son records and and thank you
so much Sam Burrell yeah I'll be a cab
City you know in a April 3rd Austin yeah
that's a great club yeah so and Houston
whatever fest I'll be at Bonnaroo this
year some stuff like that I'll call you
should talk star when you plug at the
end all right